If you use Windows for office
applications or to browse the internet,
you may not realize there is a
management console that you can run that
allows you to build a customized view of
utilities that can help you when you're
troubleshooting. This is accessed by
running mmc.exe
and obviously the MMC stands for the
Microsoft Management Console.
When you start the console, it's empty,
but you can add additional utilities
into this view so that everything is
listed on this one screen. So, from here
you can see I've added Event Viewer,
Disk Management, Task Scheduler, and
other utilities.
Let's start the Management Console on my
computer. We'll simply type mmc and we
will run that command. It asks us if we
would like this app to make changes to
the device and we would, and here is our
empty Microsoft Management Console.
This, of course, starts as an empty
console, but it's very easy to add
additional functions by going to the
File pull-down menu and choosing the
option to add and remove a snap-in. The
snap-in is the list of these different
utilities that you can add into the
Microsoft Management Console, and there
are a number of utilities to add. Let's
add Computer Management and we'll click
Add. When we add this particular
snap-in, it asks if we would like to use
this to manage our local computer or a
different computer that may be on our
network. In this case, we'll choose our
local computer and choose finish, and
you can see that it has moved Computer
Management Local into that right window.
Let's also add Device Manager, and we
can see that's added to the right side,
and we'll also load Disk Management as
well. And again, we're going to choose
this computer for Disk Management, and
then we'll click OK. And you can see on
the left side, we've now populated those
three utilities into the Microsoft
Management Console, and we can easily
access any one of them by clicking on
that particular utility and accessing
all of the features of each one of those
functions.
I've now built a customized view of the
different functions that I would like to
have available, and I would like to save
this console by again choosing the file
pull-down menu, choosing the save
option, and then we'll simply call this
PMV1
and save this particular console.
We can now pull up this management
console at any time, and I can move from
one configuration to another by loading
that configuration from disk.
One of the utilities we can add into
this list is the Event Viewer. This
gives you a consolidated view of
everything that's happening inside of
your Windows operating system. This is
effectively your Windows log viewer, and
it separates things into different
categories. You'll probably see
categories for application, security,
setup, and system.
You'll see that some of these events are
marked as informational, but they could
be marked as a warning, error, critical,
successful audit, or failure audit. If
you wanted to start up the Event Viewer
individually, you could start it as its
own application by running eventvwr.msc.
In our management console, if we click
the Event Viewer, you'll see the number
of events that we've had over time.
There are administrative events, what we
may have recently viewed, and a summary
of the log information. If you want to
quickly view a category of logs, you can
choose them from the left menu. Let's
choose the Application Windows logs, and
it lists all of the applications that
are running on our system, and we can
view the current status of a particular
log. For example, this is a log for
source called VSS. This is the Volume
Shadow Copy Service, and it tells us
that we had an error associated with
that service. It gives us details on
what that error may be.
But you'll notice that there are
thousands and thousands of logs that are
contained within this Windows Event
Viewer. So, we can filter the current
log to specify a particular event level,
a particular type of log, or details
about the category, keywords, a specific
user, or an individual computer. This
allows you to find exactly what you're
looking for very quickly without having
to page through many different log
entries.
A useful tool for examining information
about your storage system is the Disk
Management Utility. Disk Management
allows you to see all of the different
storage drives that are installed into
your computer and how those drives may
be partitioned and what file systems
they might be running.
You can run this directly from your
Management Console or open it separately
using diskmgmt.msc.
One important thing to keep in mind when
you're working with Disk Management or
any function dealing with our storage
drives is that you could potentially
delete data. So, make sure if you're
making any significant changes inside of
Disk Management that you always have a
backup of that data.
Here's the Disk Management function on
my local computer. You can see I have a
single drive and it is split into three
separate partitions. Two of these
partitions do not have drive letters
associated with them. This would be our
recovery partition and an EFI system
partition. This is used by the operating
system during the startup process or
when you're trying to install new
software on your computer.
There's also a partition that contains
the bulk of our operating system. This
is our C drive. You can see there is a
drive letter associated with it. This is
a drive that is formatted with NTFS and
it is encrypted with BitLocker, which is
a full disk encryption utility. This
also tells us that this is a healthy
partition. It is used for boot. We have
our page file on this drive. Crash dumps
are stored to this partition and this is
a basic data partition. If you have
other storage drives and partitions on
this system, they will also appear in
this disk management front end.
If you right mouse click on this
partition, you'll notice you have
options to make changes. You can change
the drive letter and the paths that are
used. You can shrink this particular
volume, and if you have additional space
on this drive or if you have additional
drives, you can choose to extend the
volume or mirror the information across
separate physical drives.
Again, you want to be very careful about
making any changes inside of this
utility because you could potentially
lose data on that storage drive.
The Task Scheduler utility allows you to
run applications at a particular date,
time, or on a recurring basis. There are
also a number of predefined tasks and
schedules that are built into Task
Scheduler, which makes it very easy to
automate functions inside of Windows.
And if you have a large number of
different tasks that you're running, you
can separate them into folders to keep
everything organized inside of Task
Scheduler. If you want to run Task
Scheduler by itself, you can run task
sched.msc.
The main screen of Task Scheduler will
show you all of the tasks that have run
in the last 24 hours. You can change
that time frame to widen it to the last
7 days or the last 30 days. If you
choose the option for your Task
Scheduler library, it shows you all of
the tasks that are currently configured.
For example, I have one configured,
which is the Microsoft update task that
it runs at 10:50 a.m. every day, and it
gives you information about how that
task is configured. You can modify these
by changing the Triggers tab, the
actions that occur, the conditions that
this is waiting for, and any detailed
settings about this task. If you'd like
to add your own task that runs at a
particular time and day, you simply
create a task on the right side menus
and put in the name of the utility that
you'd like to run, what day and time
you'd like to run it, and make sure that
any of the conditions or settings are
configured for that particular task.
Most operating systems have some type of
device driver that allows the operating
system to talk to the hardware of your
computer. To be able to see this device
driver and understand the relationship
between the operating system and the
hardware, you can use the device manager
option within your Microsoft Management
Console. Generally, the drivers that
you'll find inside of this list have
been created specifically for the
operating system that you're using. So,
if you're running Windows 10, these will
be Windows 10 device drivers. If you're
using Windows 11, these are probably
Windows 11 device drivers. There might
be some situations where a device driver
has been specifically written to work
across multiple operating systems, but
most of the time you're downloading and
installing a device driver that is
specific to this operating system. If
you want to run Device Manager by
itself, you run devmgmt.msc.
Device Manager organizes all of your
hardware into different groups. For
example, if you wanted a list of all of
the printers associated with your
computer, you can right mouse click on
printer to expand that category and see
all of the device drivers for printers.
Let's do the same thing for display
adapters. We'll also expand the keyboard
options that we're using and the option
for monitors. If we double click on any
one of these, it brings up the device
driver properties and we can see the
name of the driver that's being used,
any details associated with the driver,
any recent events associated with this
device driver, and what resources are
being used inside of our system to
support this hardware.
Many device drivers also have their own
process for installation and update.
There are also options if you right
mouse click on a driver to update,
disable, or uninstall this device
driver.
We rely on certificates to provide
information about ownership of a
computer or to enable encryption
functions within our operating system.
If you'd like to view all of the
certificates associated with your
computer, you'll find that under the
certificate manager. You'll notice that
you can run this from the certmgr.msc
option.
Here's a view of the certificate
manager. Inside of the cert manager, we
can add, remove, or view the
certificates that are already installed.
For example, you might want to see all
of the trusted certification authorities
or CAs that are used by your browser.
So, if you double-click on the trusted
root certification authorities and
choose the option for certificates, you
will see all of those certificates
listed. We can right mouse click on any
one of these to open the cert and look
at the details of this particular
certification.
Windows is a multi-user operating
system, and you can configure multiple
users to be able to use your computer or
connect to your computer across the
network. You can configure rights and
permissions for those users and group
them together into separate groups using
the local users and groups utility.
There are a number of users that are
built into Windows. For example, the
administrator user and the guest user.
Everyone else is considered a regular
user inside of Windows. There are also a
number of predefined groups, such as
administrators, users, backup operators,
power users, and others. And you can, of
course, add additional users and
additional groups into this list.
From the local users and groups option,
we can double-click on any of these to
see what the options might be. This is a
relatively new Windows build, so there
are very few users that are listed. You
can see the administrator user, the
default account, and the guest are
listed along with my user, Professor, on
this particular computer. If you'd like
to add more users, you can right mouse
click and choose new user and fill in
the details to add another user to your
computer.
One of the challenges we often have with
troubleshooting problems is many of
those issues occur in the past and by
the time we're looking at that computer,
the problem is long gone. One of the
ways to track resource utilization over
time would be with the performance
monitor utility. We can gather a great
deal of statistics from a single
computer by using the performance
monitor and if you want to launch
performance monitor by itself, you
simply run perfmon.msc.
We're able to collect metrics over a
very long time frame with performance
monitor and you can collect hundreds of
different resource metrics inside of
Windows including operating system
metrics for disk, memory, CPU and then
we can also set alarms and alerts. So,
if we exceed a particular resource
level, we can have a notification sent
directly to us.
We can also collect this information and
store it on this computer over hours,
days or weeks. This allows us to go back
in time and see everything that may have
occurred with that particular resource.
You can also create reports that allow
you to view that information over time
so that you can instantly see a
graphical view of exactly what's
occurred on this computer.
Here's the default view of performance
monitor. You can see it's looking at
memory information, network interface
details, physical disk information and
processor information. We can also add
additional monitoring tools into this
view by starting the performance monitor
graph. Here's the default view of
performance monitor. You can see that
it's not currently collecting any
particular metrics. To add additional
metrics into this list, we'll click the
plus sign and you will see that a large
number of categories of counters show up
on the left hand side. This is a huge
amount of information. you certainly
wouldn't want to add all of them to your
computer at one time. But in this list,
let's scroll down under the processor
section, and if I highlight this, we can
view all of the different metrics that
are collected. Let's choose all of them
by default. We'll click the add option,
and it puts the processor option on the
right side, and we'll click okay. Now
we're going to start gathering metrics
about how the processor of this system
happens to be performing, and you can
see that all of these different options
are being collected and displayed on
this graph in real time.
This means that we can begin collecting
this data, we can go away, and if the
problem on this computer occurs again,
we can come back and look at the
historical view of these metrics to see
if we might be able to break down where
the problem might be occurring on this
computer.
As the administrator of your Windows
system, you can have granular control
over what features might be available to
different users. The way to manage this
process is through the Group Policy
Editor. If you're editing policies for
an individual system, then you would be
using the Local Group Policy Editor, or
gpedit.msc,
but if you're part of a larger
organization that has Active Directory
infrastructures, then you're probably
going to use Group Policy Management
Console that integrates with that
centralized Active Directory Management.
You'll find that under gpmc.msc.
Here's the local computer policy on my
computer, and from here you can see
there are two main categories of
computer configuration and user
configuration. If we select user
configuration and look at the
administrative templates, we can view
options, for example, the desktop. Here
are the options that we have available
to manage what people can do on the
desktop of this computer. For example,
if you want to hide and disable all
items on the desktop, you can configure
that inside of the policy manager, so
that when someone logs in, they don't
see anything on the desktop of their
computer.